[Music]
a 21st century assignment for fighter
jets designed in the 70s and pressed
into service by the Soviet Air Force in
the 80s
these migs we are giving to Ukraine so
they can protect their civilians from
the amount of bombs that have been
hitting their homes and shelters where
civilians are dying Slovakia's
government approved the transfer of 13
mig-29s to Ukraine the Jets had been
grounded because of a lack of spare
parts and technicians to service them
Poland this week also finalized plans to
send four Jets what's that
you see it was just last month when
Ukraine's defense minister waved a
pocket square with a jet on it teasing
what he wanted from his NATO allies
but Russia also has friends China Xi
Jinping will spend three days in Moscow
next week the West has expressed fears
China would arm Russia and recently urge
she against such actions Germany
suggested China use its sway to convince
the Kremlin to withdraw from Ukraine
China will uphold its objective and fair
position on the Ukrainian crisis says
the spokesperson for the Chinese foreign
Ministry when it comes to Russia's war
in Ukraine Putin's advisers told a state
media Outlet must go highly appreciates
the balanced position of the Chinese
leadership Russia's full invasion of its
neighbor last year prompted Sweden and
Finland which shares a land border with
Russia to seek security under the NATO
Banner thank you after lengthy talks the
Turkish Parliament will start the
ratification process for Finland talks
continue on Sweden's bid turkey and
Hungary had previously blocked The Joint
NATO bid Hungary now says it will also
start the ratification process for
Finland Russia previously warned that it
would be forced to respond should NATO
set up military infrastructure along the
borders of the Nordic countries